في هذه المقابله مع مصطفى هجري زعيم الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستانيه الايرانيه المعارض
مسؤول مركز الاداره العامه في الحزب السيد
مصطفى اهلا بك وشكرا على قبولك الحديث
معنا شكرا لكم ايضا انتم اكبر واقدم
الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه المعارضه
تتابعون ما يرجى الان في ايران من
احتجاجات بدات منذ اشهر كيف تقيمون هذه
المظاهرات الان
انتظر الشعب الايراني طويلا فرصه الثوره
ضد جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
لكن المظاهرات لم تعد تقتصر على
مدن بعرقيه وثنيات بعينها وانما عمات
الكثير من المدن الايرانيه هذا الامر
مختلف هذه المره
هل تعتقدون بانا ستستمر طويلا
انتشرت الثوره خلال الاشهر الاربعه
الماضيه بدا الشعب الايراني في مقاومه
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه منذ اعلانيها على وجه
الخصوص كان الشعب الكردي والحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني في ايران يقاتلون
النظام على مدار 43 عاما الماضيه نعتقد ان
الثوره ستستمر حتى اسقاط النظام الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه قد يكون هناك صعود وهبوط اثناء
الثوره لكن الثوره ستنجح
انتم كحسب ديمقراطي كردستاني ايراني معارض
في هذه المظاهرات النظام الايرانيه يقول
انكم همم تقودون المظاهرات تسلحون
المتظاهرين وتثيرون الشعب هذا بحسب
الروايه الايرانيه كيف تردون على هذه
التحهم
في مدينه الزقازيق في كردستان الاحزاب
الكرديه كجزء من مركز التعاون المكون من
حزبين دعونا الشعب الى الاضراب والنزول
الى الشوارع للاحتجاج على الجريمه التي
ارتكبها النظام تابع الناس نداءنا واضربوا
وبدوا الاحتجاجات بدات الاحتجاجات
بالانتشار من كردستان الى مناطق اخرى في
ايران كما شاهدنا لم تختصر الاحتجاجات على
الحدود الايرانيه ولكن ايضا على
الايرانيين في الشتاء تدفق الى الشوارع
خاصه في الولايات المتحده واورو اوروبا
مظهرين الدعم والتضامن مع الايرانيين داخل
ايران
انت ماشي مع عقليتها القديمه اتهمتنا
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بالوقوف وراء
الاحتجاجات لاحقا بدا النظام بقصف
المخيمات التي تعيش فيها عائلتنا في
كردستان العراق استشهد عدد من المشمركه من
حزبنا وافراد عائلتهم في قصف النظام قررت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هجماتها بالصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره الانتحاريه
المظاهرات والدعوه للتظاهر وانما اتهام
النظام لكم يتعلق
بارسال سلاح تهريب سلاح يصل الى
المتظاهرين هذه التهمه همم الاساسيه من
قبل النظام الايراني
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه ردا على اي
احتجاج من قبل الشعب الايراني حتى
الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت القتل الوحشي
لامراه بسبب عدم ارتدائها حجاب الرا بشكل
مناسب يتهم النظام الجميع بانهم عملاء
للاجانب وانهم اعداء الاسلام ووفقا لهذه
العقليه يتهم النظام حزبنا بارسال اسلحه
الى داخله ايران في الواقع يقف الشعب ضد
قوات امن نظام بايديهم العاريه الناس
يطالبون بحقوقهم في الشوارع بايديهم
النظام يواجه مثل هذه الاتهامات من اجل
تبرير قتل المتظاهرين امام اعين العالم
انها ذريعه للنظام لتبرير موقفه اثناء قتل
الشعب لا لم نرسل اسلحه الى الداخل ايران
الشعب ليسوا مسلحين يقف الشعب ضد النظام
بايديهم في 2016 تحدثتم عن العوده لكفاح
المسلح هل فعلا انتم الان في مرحله الكفاح
المسلح ام عدتم الى مرحله وقف اطلاق النار
لدينا قوات بشمرقه مسلحه ومع ذلك لم تنضم
قواتنا الى الاحتجاجات في ايران لا نخطط
لجعلهم يتدخلون في الوضع الحالي الافضل لو
استمرت الاحتجاجات بشكل مدني وبعيدا عن
العنف في حاله العنف يمكن للنظام قتل
واداء المزيد من شعبنا لدينا قوات بشمرقه
يتم تدريبها لكننا لا نخطط لنشرها في
ايران بدلا من ذلك نحاول مساعده
الاحتجاجات المدنيه وان نكون صوتهم في
وسائل الاعلام الدوليه للتواصل مع
الامريكيين والاوروبيين والدعوه لمطالب
الشعب الايراني للشعب قضيه عادله ويجبوا
تلبيه مطالبهم لذلك ليس لدينا خطه
لاستخدام الاسلحه في المستقبل القريب نامل
على ان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه سوف تسقط مع
الاحتجاجات المدنيه الحاليه
او حكم فيدراليه ولكن النظام الايرانيه
يتهم ويكون تسعه وللانفصال هل انتم من
دعاه الانفصال من السعين للانفصال
كما اعلنا بوضوح في برامج حزبنا نحن نعمل
من اجل ايران فيدراليه وديمقراطيه ايران
حيث الاكراد وغيرهم من الشعوب المضطهده
مثل العرب والبلوش والتركمان والاتراك
لديهم اداره ذاتيه للمشاركه على قدم
المساواه في مستقبل البلاد نريد ان تكون
ايران لكل الايرانيين وليس فقط لمجموعه
قوميه او دينيه لذلك ننكر الاتهامات باننا
انفصاليون في
الاوساط الكرديه هناك من يعتقد بان هذا
تراجع عن فكر القاده والزعماء الاوائل
للحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايرانيه
المعارض الدكتور قاسم لو مثلا كردستاني
كردستان المستقله عن ايران لم تكن ابدا
على جدول اعمال الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني منذ انشائها لم ندافع
ابدا عن الاستقلال لقد دعمنا دائما فكره
ان تكون جزءا من ايران طالبنا بالحكم
الذاتي وقد مر وقت طويل حتى نطالب بنظام
فيدرالي لايران ولكن كيف تحقق هذا الحكم
فيدرالي الجيد والايجابي للكثير من
الاعراق والاثنيات في داخل الايراني هل
يمكن ان يحقق هكذا مشروع في ظل هذا النظام
الحالي الايراني
مثل كوماري اسلام ايران ما في انتهكت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الحقوق العرقيه كما
انتهكت الحقوق الفرديه الاحتجاجات التي
نشهدها الان هي ثمار 43 عاما من حكم
النظام طالما استمرت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
في الوجود فلن تتحقق حقوقنا ومطالبنا هذا
هو الاستنتاج الذي توصل اليه الناس ايضا
لذلك يطالب الشعب في الشوارع في ايران
باسقاط الجمهوريه الاسلاميه نحن نوحدوا
جهودنا من اجل مستقبل ما بعد الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران حيث دوله فيدراليه
وعلمانيه وديمقراطيه سيكون التشكيل
السياسي الحاكم وسيتم احترامه حقوق جميع
الاعراف
الكرديه بين الجماعات المعارضه الكرديه
الايرانيه
مختلفه في الشعرات في الافكار في المطالب
ان تحدثنا مثلا عن مجاهد خلق ما علاقتكم
بهم
في السابق كانت لدينا علاقات جيده مع
مجاهدين خلق كنا جزءا من تحالف لاحقا كانت
هناك مشاكل بيننا تركنا التحالف التي
كانوا جزءا منه وصلنا انشطتنا المستقله
ونحن منخرطون في حوار مستمر مع كل مجموعات
المعارضه الايرانيه بما في ذلك الجماعات
اليمنيه واليساريه حتى مع مجاهدي خلق
لدينا حوار ومع ذلك لدينا تحالف فقط مع
المجموعات التي تمثل الشعوب والاثنيات
الايرانيه نحن اعضاء في تحالف يسمى مؤتمر
شعوبه ايران الفيدراليه يتكون هذا
الائتلاف من عدد من الاحزاب العربيه
البلوش الترك التركمان والاكراد نواصل
المحادثات مع مجموعات المعارضه الاخرى ليس
لدينا تضارب في المصالح لاننا نعتقد انه
يجب ان نتحد حيث ان هدفنا النهائي هو سقوط
نظام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ماذا عن دعاه
العوده للحكم الملكي نظام بهويه
نظام ايران المستقبلي يجب ان يقررها شعب
الايراني يمكن القيام بذلك من خلال
استفتاء اذا صوت غالبيه الشعب الايراني
لنظام الملكي فيجب ان يتم ذلك
الايراني والمظاهرين هل تعتقدون ان
الاصلاحين مؤهللون
لفتره من الوقت اجراء اصلاحات داخل النظام
لم يستمع نظام اليهم تم سجن معظمهم تم
اعدام بعضهم فقد شعب الامل في امكانيه
اصلاح النظام هذا هو سبب مطالبهم باسقاط
النظام الايراني
هل ستقبلون
بهذا الحوار ايه
لقد جربنا ذلك مع النظام منذ بدايه
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بعد انتهاء الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه جربنا ايضا المفاوضات
مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ومع ذلك فقد تم
توضيح ان انخراط النظام في المفاوضات كان
يهدف الى مؤامره لذلك فقد فات الاوان الان
بالنسبه لنا للدخول في المفاوضات مع
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه بعد الاصلاحيين
بالاضافه الى نواب في البرلمان الايراني
كذلك حتى بعض السياسيين يتحدثون اليوم عن
ضروره الاصلاح داخل هذا النظام الايراني
الى اي درجه تعتقد بين النظام مستعد
ليقوم باي اجراءات اصلاحيه
رجيم كوماري اسلام ايران لا اظهرت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه خلال كل سنوات حكمها
انها غير قادره على اجراء اصلاحات نظام
يحكم بايديولوجيته ويستمر مصادره من تلك
القاعده الجيولوجيه ترفض الاصلاحات هذه
الايدلوجيه بعد 43 عاما جلبت البطاله
والفقر فقط للشعب الايراني والنظام يتعرض
لضغوط دوليه ومع ذلك لم يوافق النظام على
تقديم اي تنازلات بشان اديولوجيهته لذلك
فان جهود اصلاح الجمهوريه الاسلاميه قديما
ولا تؤدي الى نتائج الان لم يعد الشعب
يطالب بالاصلاحات فقدوا الامل في
الاصلاحاتكم في كردستان العراق انتم
تعيشون هنا منذ سنوات
مرتاحين في قناتكم تشعرون بامانه
تحت الضغط
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه منذ ان تمركزنا هنا
اغتيل العشرات من اعضاء حزبنا على يد
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في العراق قصفت
صواريخ الجمهوريه الاسلاميه قواعدنا
ومخيمات اللاجئين ليس ذلك فحسب بل نفذت
القوه البريه التابعه للنظام ايضا عمليات
ضد حزبنا ومع ذلك فقد قومنا حتى الان
ونواصل العمل لتحقيق اجنده حزبنا سوف
نقاوم ونستمر في الوجود
تستهدفكم كجماعات كرديه ايرانيه معارضه
ماذا ان نفذت ايران تحديدها
كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا الوضع
من قبل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه على كردستان
العراق سندافع عن انفسنا سنقاوم قصف
النظام بكل قوتنا كما فعلنا حتى اليوم
على اربيل بغداد قد يؤدي في مرحله ما الى
موقفا عراقي يقضي بابعادكم من هذا المنطقه
او على الاقل بسحب السلاح منكم
على حكومه الاقليم لنزع السلاح
مركز
الاستمرار في القيام بذلك سوف نحمي انفسنا
لان بغداد واربيل تتعرضان دائما لضغ نظام
الايراني هل ترى ان النظام الايراني
متماسك وقوي
اليوميه النظام يعاني من وضع الاقتصادي
رهيب النظام يفقد شرعيته كما نشهد استمرار
الاحتجاجات المطالبه بانهائه اسقط
المتظاهرون الرموز الاديولوجيه للنظام تم
تشويه تماثيل قاسم سليماني وخمني وحتى
الخميني في الاحتجاجات كانت بعض المرجعيات
الدينيه في النظام تحتج على سلوك النظام
نفسه يشعر الجيش وقوه الامن بنوع من
العصيان داخل صفوفهم يواجه النظام من جميع
الجوانب تحديا فوضيا هذا وضع لا يستطيع
النظام التراجع عنه والعوده الى الوضع
الذي كان عليه قبل الاحتجاجات سيستمر وضع
النظام في التدهور مع مرور الوقت
رسالتنا الى المحتاجين الاكراد
والايرانيين هي ان الطريقه الوحيده لتجديد
مطالبهم للوصول الى حريتهم والعيش حياه
كريمه يعتمدوا اكثر من اي شيء اخر على
سقوط النظام لذلك لتحقيق هذه الاهداف يجب
ان نتحد جميعا ضد النظام يجب ان نتحد ايضا
في تاسيس تشكيل ديمقراطيه قائم على مطالب
الشعب
سابقا هل تعتقدون انكم سيد مصطفى كزعيم
لحزب الديمقراطيه الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض
هدف للامن الايراني وكيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الوضع
حاول نظام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه مرات عده
اغتيال تمكنا من احباط مخططاتهم في احدى
محاولاتهم قبل حوالي 20 عاما بمجرد عوده
من زياره قوات البشمركه قامت الجمهوريه
الايرانيه بزرع بعض الالغام على الطريق
صارت سياره حراسه فوق احد الالغام فقدنا
بعد قوات البشمركه واصيب البعض الاخر لم
يتمكن النظام الايراني من تحقيق اهدافه في
التامر ضدي مصطفى هجري زعيم الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني المعارض
مسؤول مركز الاداره العامه في الحزب
الديمقراطي شكرا جزيلا لك على قبول الحديث
معنا واجره هذه المقابله الاولى لكم منذ
بدء المظاهرات الايرانيه شكرا